auf dieser schuppen look nun von seewolf
lachs oder papageienfische stand lässt
sich für den laien nicht erkennen
in jedem fall werden hier in grafing bei
münchen schuhe mit leder von fischen
hergestellt denn deren haut kann häufig
genauso gegerbt werden wie die von
säugetieren
damit eignet sich für schläger für
schuhe aus natürlichem material so
dachte sich zumindest die schumacher
brüder koppitz wie einer von ihnen
erzählt seien sie auf die idee gekommen
nachdem sie das leder nur mal so aus dem
internet bestellt hätten dessen
verarbeitung sei gewöhnungsbedürftig
gewesen so florian kubitz und werden
dann eingefärbt damit die einheitlichen
von der farbe her
mit jeder fisch so stark unterschiedlich
die verarbeitung ist nicht so einfach
durch das dass sie kleiner sank von der
haut her und es sehr unterschiedliche es
wird viel filigraner zu verarbeiten
dieser feinere vorgehen hat seinen preis
also wer fisch nee das haben wir schon
über 1000 euro und nach oben hin ist
wenig grenzen ist also 2000 euro sie ist
auch möglich
immerhin benötigen die grafinger
handwerker pro partie zwischen drei
tagen und einer woche im jahr kommen sie
auf rund 45 paar schuhe
eine offizielle auszeichnung gab es
schon neben der exklusivität preisen sie
selbst die haltbarkeit ihrer produkte
bis zu 20 jahre lebensdauer sein da drin
und dann sei ihre leder variante auch
noch nachhaltig da kein tier extra dafür
sterben müsse die fisch heute fallen bei
der lebensmittelproduktion sowieso an
und würden sonst weggeworfen
ein flüssiger geruch ist übrigens auch
kein thema der geht beim gerben verloren